ein paar tage lang schien corona so ein
bisschen raus aus unserem alltag in
deutschland dank der
us-präsidentschaftswahl die so
wahnsinnig spannend war uns alle in den
bann gezogen hat über mehrere tage bis
zum ergebnis joe biden also hier happy
im kreis seiner familie wird künftig ins
weiße haus einziehen aber mit dem
ergebnis kommt sofort corona knallharte
in unseren alltag zurück und wie sehr
sie dieses thema beschäftigt das zeigt
dass sie so viele hunderte mails uns
geschickt haben mit fragen an den
bundesgesundheitsminister vor wenigen
minuten ist er ihr vor gefahren vor das
bild hochhaus und ich werde ihnen gleich
ganz viele ihrer fragen stellen in der
korona sprichst du und jetzt live bei
bild ist hier im studio live bei bild
herzlich willkommen und des
gesundheitsministeriums bahn schönen
guten abend der weise danke für den
november haben sie und die kanzlerin
allen deutschen gesagt sie sollen ihre
kontakte um 75 prozent reduzieren machen
sie das haben sie reduziert um 75
prozent
ich habe jedenfalls wie alle bürgerinnen
und bürger auch enorm reduziert das
sieht man ja ich meine restaurants sind
so freizeitveranstaltungen sind viele
nicht mehr möglich sport also vieles was
ja auch vielen schwer fällt das ist
verzicht aber eben verzichten notwendig
ist um es diesem wäre schwer zu machen
das ist ja wissen jetzt dass banal aber
auch das schwierige an diesem virus ist
einfach ist überträgt sich da am
leichtesten wo menschen zusammenkommen
und das müssen wir alle reduzieren und
das habe ich auch gemacht übrigens auch
noch mehr videokonferenzen wie wir alle
jetzt im november als in den letzten
wochen also das heißt noch mal
aufgezählt restaurants verzichten sie
sie verzichten im moment auf ihren sport
vielleicht vor im fitnessstudio gewesen
mehr videokonferenzen dass das ist es
das bringt 75 prozent auf 5 17 prozent
ist ja echt schwer 75 prozent ist sehr
schwer da bin ich bei ihnen tatsächlich
ist home office alleine jedenfalls
schwer möglich weil die auch
präsenztermine dabei sind wegen eine
kabinettssitzung und ist auch schon
wichtig finde dass der
gesundheitsminister in der gesundheits
krise auch im ministerium ist insofern
versuchen wir kontakte zu reduzieren wo
es geht wie alle anderen auch aber es
geht eben nicht überall herr weise sie
sind ja genauso hier in der redaktion
auch ob wir uns genau bei der arbeit ist
total also die die zahl 75 glauben sie
dass sie annähernd daran kommen bei 50
landen jetzt geht wissen sie wohl am
ende ist das finde ich 75 ist natürlich
eine größe aus der aus der mathematik
aus der statistik die ja vor allem eins
beschreiben soll auch in dieser
größenordnung das werden wir dieses
virus wieder unter kontrolle bringen
wollen
die tägliche zahl der neuinfektionen die
wir sehen von jens über um die 20.000 in
den letzten tagen wenn wir das runter
bringen wollen geht das eben nur wenn
wir es diesem virus möglichst schwer
machen schlicht und ergreifend sich zu
übertragen von einem zum anderen zu
springen und das geht eben nur wenn wir
insgesamt weniger kontakte haben das ist
ja die entscheidende botschaft und mein
eindruck ist ich weiß nicht wie sie es
wahrnehmen
die allermeisten bürgerinnen und bürger
so schwer ist fällt machen da eben auch
genau ganz genau deshalb frage ich falls
da ja und um die vorbildfunktion geht
nicht nur bei ihnen sondern bei vielen
prominenten bei sportlern bei
schauspielern usw
es ist so ein eindruck bei vielen dass
sich doch sehr viele auch selbst
fußballer die unter fast sterilen
bedingungen eigentlich offiziell im
moment leben sich dann ansteckend
fraktion immer nur wie kommt das haben
die sich vielleicht doch nicht ganz so
strenge ja mein geist wissen das problem
ist ja nehmen sie ein restaurant das
beste hygiene konzept schafft es ja
nicht das risiko auf null zu bringen
also auch abstand
ich habe man schon mal die nächste frage
ist eher wie lange ist man zusammen in
einem raum also die das entscheidende
übrigens über den november hinaus jetzt
in der kalten jahreszeit wird der sein
die zeit die ich zusammen mit anderen
vor allem mit vielen anderen in einen
raum verbringen zu reduzieren
also statt einer stunde vielleicht nur
20 minuten meeting zu machen und dann im
zweifel mal treffen zu machen dann mal
da mal zu zu lüften und insgesamt immer
wieder im blick zu haben zu viele in
einem raum ist problematischen das gilt
bei einem restaurant das beste hygiene
konzept wenn da zwei drei infizierte im
raum sind ohne es zu wissen über 2 34
stunden und
alle reden im restaurant hat so redet
man viel dann verbreitet es sich einfach
und dann ist dieses virus ebenso dass es
sich dann auch in einem solchen raum
übertragen kann trotz wir gehen ein
konzept ist konzerne konzept bringt das
risiko runter aber es bringt es nicht
auf null und das finde ich aha regeln
machen einen enormen unterschieden
unsere wirksamste waffe abstand hygiene
alltags maske aber ist sich reduzieren
das nicht auf so werden jetzt nicht
misstrauisch wenn beispielsweise ein
beispiel fc bayern münchen da gibt es
die ersten corona fälle und dann sagt
man wie kann das passieren
da werden sie nicht misstrauisch die
waren dann abends eben doch aus oder
haben dann doch zu hause gefeiert sind
nicht misstrauisch
das heißt der misstrauisch ich wissen
habe ich vorhin noch mit jemandem drüber
gesprochen bei viruserkrankungen die
sich so übertragen fängt ja ganz schnell
die schuld debatte an
man fühlt sich ja auch schuldig und
denkt sich dann möglicherweise habe ich
jemand anders angesteckt und sie geben
und sie außerhalb von der regierung auch
die verantwortung sagen nur würden sich
daran halten liebe bürger dann wird es
schon alles flott laufen dass diese
assistenten ist ja miteinander in der
gesellschaft
im übrigen machen will wie alle jetzt
auch als bürgerinnen und bürger will
machen so nicht für die regierung also
machen und sagen na wenn's schief geht
dann können wir eben kein weihnachten
feiern aber sie haben es in der hand das
war ja mal ganz lange die formuliert wir
haben alles selbst in der hand wir klar
wir es selbst in der hand wer denn auch
sonst
und am ende geht es auch darum dass
jeder für sich so schwer dass fällt es
gelingt auch nie zu 100 prozent wir sind
menschen nicht perfekt aber wir können
ja immer wieder versuchen für uns selbst
und für die in unserem umfeld vor allem
für die familie für die freunde für die
arbeitskolleginnen und kollegen
bestmöglich aufeinander zu achten
darum geht es doch und das immer auch
mitzudenken und ich glaube was eine
große rolle gespielt hatte ich mein ich
habe schon im august september wie
andere auch gesagt hochzeit feiern ist
vielleicht dieses jahr nicht die so
schwer es fällt ich meine habe oft genug
selbst auf westfälischen hochzeiten
gekellnert früher eine zahl der
scheidungen schweren so schwer es fällt
auf diese feier zu verzichten die dann
so gehört aber das ist jetzt halt eine
jahrhundert situation und dann gehen
manche dinge eben nicht oder zumindest
nicht so wie wir sie gewohnt waren und
das miteinander mitzunehmen das ist das
entscheidende
und mein eindruck ist schon nicht wenn
sie sich umschauen auf der welt wir
haben bis hierhin und sie müssen immer
wieder aufs neue darum werben und auch
dafür einstehen
bis hierhin ein hohes mitmachen der
bevölkerung weil viele im sagen sie
sehen für sich selbst und für ihr umfeld
auch nutzen darin mitzumachen sie
unterstützen die maßnahmen sie
unterstützen die aha regeln und sie
versuchen jedenfalls bestmöglich sie im
alltag zudem und dass ich ein enormes
von wie wir wissen sie hatten ja nun
selbst corona haben sich angesteckt
haben die erkrankung überstanden relativ
gut überstanden wie sie uns mitgeteilt
haben und nun haben sie danach gesagt
nun ist einiges doch anders fusion wie
anders an fortan als gesundheitsminister
aufgehört zu treten andere erfahrung was
genau ist anders jetzt mit dieser
erfahrung nicht zuerst einmal ist es
schon was anderes
zehn monate neun bis zehn monate ab
januar mit dem virus politisch umzugehen
organisatorisch umzugehen oder eben es
zu haben schlecht was macht es aus also
machen wir das die gleichen gedanken wie
alle anderen sich auch gemacht haben wie
ist der verlauf was passiert jetzt
gedanken mit wem habe ich kontakt wir
sind die kontaktpersonen wie informieren
wir die schnellstmöglich also all die
dinge die wir sozusagen bisher
beschrieben habe auf was alles zu achten
ist und was alles in den blick zu nehmen
ist die haben dann mich wie jetzt im
moment übrigens stand heute 200.000
deutsche die aktiv die infektion haben
und übrigens einige hunderttausend
deutsche die heute stand heute in
quarantäne senden so auch in einer nicht
leichten situation sind und das habe ich
halt ja jetzt auch einmal durchgemacht
wie viele andere 30 prozent fühlen oder
sind wurden am ende nicht um mich
aber sie interessieren wir sind hier
mitten in der pandemie und dann gehts
irgendwie nicht um die befindlichkeit
ist gesundheit sie haben gesagt das
macht sie das macht sie machen mich
dankbar und demütig hab ich gesagt aber
dann habe ich auch keine also ich finde
es irgendwie dann auch nicht angemessen
wenn ich jetzt mit ihnen eine halbe
stunde darüber philosophieren halblangen
braunen demütig das versprechen von
ihrem gesundheitsminister erwarten die
bürger zu recht was anderes als die
infrage kamen ganz oft und wir gucken
uns einmal eine frage an von nadine
jungen die uns geschrieben hat aus zell
am harmersbach und sie hat geschrieben
ich würde brennend interessieren wie sie
der gesundheitsminister sich angesteckt
haben für mich ist das der supergau
schreibt sie der frage ich mich doch
haben sie sich nicht an die regeln
gehalten das haben wir geklärt die uns
auferlegt haben oder bringen diese
maßnahmen dann eben doch nichts also
sie kann es nicht verstehen wie sie der
so an der spitze steht sich dann eben
doch an stellt dazu erst einmal zeigt es
ja das virus macht keinen unterschied
sondern es kann jeden treffen
zum zweiten zeigte es eben das was ich
gerade gesagt habe die aha regeln
reduzieren ist nicht auf null das risiko
neuer regeln reduzieren das enorm vor
allem wenn man auf alle drei achtet
abstand hygiene alltags maske
insbesondere im geschlossenen raum wo
man auch nicht immer abstand halten kann
lüften jetzt auch noch mal wichtig aber
es bringt es nicht auf null runter und
das ist ganz wichtig auch miteinander
miteinander zu sehen und ich hab
manchmal auch den eindruck natürlich da
wo man sozusagen in den situationen ist
mit leuten die man nicht kennt u-bahn
oder möglicherweise den beruflichen
kontext ist da denkt man sich im zweifel
dass ich besonders auf und dann wenn es
so ist familiär wird denkt man sich ja
hier wird schon keiner haben also das
ist so eine erfahrung die ich manchmal
so im eigenen umfeld mache dass da wo es
privat wird und da erwischt man sich im
zweifel selbst auch bei dass das man
dann denkt ja kommen hier zu hause wird
schon keiner haben aber so ist es eben
nicht da kann es genauso gut jemand
haben also die aha regeln machen einen
unterschied das ist jetzt auch mehr als
erwiesen
offenkundig wir haben übrigens auch
viele andere virale erkrankungen sind
richtig auf dem weg nach unten in
deutschland fast keine masern infektion
und anderes mehr es macht einen
unterschied dabei sich dringend es nicht
auf null und das ist auch meine
botschaft an frau jung
hier und an viele andere mal die frage
habe ich auch häufig bekommen
wie kann das denn passieren wenn man
sich an die regeln hält es kann
passieren auch weil oder nicht weil
während man sich an die regeln hält so
ist's richtig formuliert und trotzdem
ist es wichtig die regeln einzuhalten wo
immer es geht um sich und andere zu
schützen wenn wir uns alle im alltag so
verhalten als hätten wir es und wollen
die anderen nicht anstecken wenn man mal
so rum denken dann macht es eben
tatsächlich letztes mal zu ihnen
versprochen keine halbe stunde sie
wissen nach wie vor nicht wie und wo sie
sich angesteckt haben jetzt werden die
gesundheitsbehörden in berlin alles
versucht haben das nachzuverfolgen
das ist nicht gelogen haben die nun hier
schlampig gearbeitet weil es nicht
gelungen ist aus zu finden wo hat sich
der gesundheitsminister angesteckt oder
hatten sich schlichtweg einfach vor
allem beruflich sowie kontakte dass das
eben nicht nachweisbar oder nicht heraus
zu verweisen so einfach nur nach war
überlegen wie will man das denn
überhaupt zu öffnen wenn es sozusagen
ein cluster event wie das jetzt heißt
also ein ereignis gegeben hat womit
chorprobe es gibt also die beispiele die
wir auch hatten oder waren viele bei der
chorprobe zusammen oder zusammen oft
gangelt auf einer karnevalssitzung in
einer veranstaltung eine familienfeier
die die berühmte hochzeitsfeier in hamm
das ist sozusagen ein anlass und da kann
man jedenfalls mit einer 100 prozent
weil es ja in heute jahrhundert einer
sehr hohen wahrscheinlichkeit annehmen
dass sich dort die allermeisten die dann
infiziert waren in den folgetagen dort
angesteckt haben
wenn jetzt aber jemand nicht und das ist
ja genau das problem das wir momentan
das über 75 prozent der infizierten
nicht klar zuordnen können wo es
passierten weil es eben nicht passiert
ist in dem kontext einer einer größeren
veranstaltung in einer schule einer eine
einrichtung einer feier sondern ist es
irgendwie in den letzten tagen passiert
ohne dass da ein solcher anlass war
und das ist eben genau das
infektionsgeschehen dass wir den letzten
wochen haben das uns jetzt dazu gebracht
hat diese maßnahmen seit montag
seitdem 211 eben auch wieder in kraft zu
setzen die hart sind die einschränkungen
bedeuten für viele die aber eben der
richtige antwort darauf sind dass wir es
nicht mehr eindeutig zuordnen und damit
man auch reduzieren können das ist halt
dass tricky an diesem fast ricky ist an
diesem virus eine frage die jetzt weiter
zielt auf das wie geht es eigentlich
weiter nachdem im november die konform
melanie pleger und sie sagt da unsere
grundrechte gerade massiv eingeschränkt
sind zb natürlich mit wie viele menschen
man sich treffen kann darf usw
würde ich gerne wissen schreibt sie ob
und wann wir diese grundrechte in vollem
umfang zurückerhalten oder auf das jetzt
auf ewig so bleibt diese sogenannte pd
die lage von nationaler tragweite was
können sie antwortete grundrechte zurück
also auf ewig bleibt sie sicher nicht
davon bin ich wirklich sehr überzeugt
bin auch sehr sicher dass wir schauen
sie mal von märz bis heute wissen wir
schon viel viel mehr über das wäre so
wissen wir übrigens auch haben wir auch
mehr techniken technologien die
schnelltests im september gab es noch
keine jetzt im november können wir sie
sehr großzügig nützen nutzen und ich bin
sehr sicher
im januar im märz sehen wir noch mal
neue testtechnologien andere
technologien und möglicherweise
irgendwann dann auch einen impfstoff im
laufe des nächsten jahres haben aber die
frage sozusagen auf einen monat auf eine
woche genau kann ich kann man nicht das
ist einfach die ehrliche antwort zu
sagen dass dann alles wieder so ist wie
vorher das ist jetzt absehbar für die
nächsten monate jedenfalls sicher nicht
der fall
ich finde will aber nur hinzufügen wir
machen das alles ja auch um ein anderes
grundrecht zu schützen nämlich dass auf
die körperliche unversehrtheit und
bestmöglichen gesundheitsschutz und das
ist ja der klassiker den wir an vielen
stellen haben dass wir grundrechte wo
keines absolut absolut ist gegen dann
abwägen müssen freiheits fragen gegen
gesundheitsschutz die drei ist ein
die debatte um die maske ist ja so dass
symbolthema geworden wo die einen sagen
die maske ist so ein symbol der
sklaverei hörcher dann auch gelegener
als mehr wo jemand sagt die maske trägt
man trag ich ja nicht zuerst für mich
sondern um andere zu schützen
und dann geht es also nicht nur um meine
freiheit sondern ja auch um die freiheit
der anderen und das machen wir im alltag
doch ganz häufig zu schnell fahren warum
ist das reguläre jetzt hier nicht nur
zum schutz von einem selbst sondern auch
zum schutz von anderen und dieses
abwägen von freiheitsrechten für den
einzelnen und gleichzeitig den freiheits
oder gesundheitswesen drinnen das heißt
erleben wir ja alle seit monaten sie
sagen also frau kläger die nächsten
monate auf jeden fall diese grundrechte
nicht vollständig zurück das kann man
jetzt schon sagen zum jetzigen das will
jedenfalls die nächsten monate an
verschiedenen stellen regeln brauchen
und wenn es das masken tragen im
geschlossenen raum ist für gehende
konzepte im beim einkaufen oder oder in
anderen zusammenhängen auf der arbeit ja
das wird noch eine gehört sagen ja auch
zum grundrecht dass man noch alles in
den einkaufswagen legen darf mir ist am
wochenende passiert bei
einer großen einzelhandelskette das an
der kasse wieder zurückgelegt wurde weil
gesagt worden
also im moment nur eine rolle küchen
küche küchenrolle ist das ein glaube ich
ein grundrecht auf küchenrollen aber
herr weise
naja es ist ja ist es ja etwas der
ausdruck von was anderem und da geht es
wieder um solidarität und darum dass es
nicht nur mein selbst geht
wahrscheinlich gab es gerade nicht mehr
so viel küchenrollen vorrätig enden den
jeweiligen geschäft und dann hat eben
und das ist ja genau das gleiche sehr am
ende eine entscheidung des des
geschäftes gewesen aber eben zu sagen es
geht hier nicht nur um herrn weise
sondern im zweifel auch noch um ein paar
andere kunden die eine küchenrolle
brauchen oder was auch immer kann halt
nicht ein jetzt auf einmal in zwei
pakete für eine fünfköpfige familie
sondern dass ich noch mal ein aber ich
finde das wichtig ist ein beispiel aber
es ist doch nur der versuch möglichst in
seinem inneren balance ihren wunsch ihre
freiheit ihr bedürfnis was zu kaufen
in balance zu bringen mit dem bedürfnis
von anderen das auch zu tun das ist doch
das was wir jeden tag machen das machen
wir jeden tag in der familie das machen
wir jeden tag im zweifel beim einkaufen
und das machen wir natürlich in der
politik dann regelsätzen und das ist
eben der unterschied verbindlich für das
ganze land ist trotzdem seltsame
ausdruck dieser dieser corona krise ein
kleiner ausdruck noch mal dazu wann
kommen wir wieder zurück zu normalen
regeln bis ende november gilt das jetzt
erst mal wie groß wir wie groß halten
sie die chancen dass danach november
wieder irgendwas anders ist also halten
sie das überhaupt im bereich des
möglichen zu mir zum zeitpunkt ja was
wir schaffen müssen miteinander ist
schlicht und ergreifend dass die zahlen
sinken den sie jetzt sehen signale als
wir im moment sehen aber sind die
beobachtung ist noch kein trend deswegen
finde ich sehr wichtig damit vorsichtig
umgehen was wir sehen ist dass der
dynamik sich abschwächt also steigt noch
aber es steigt deutlich weniger stark
als noch vor einer oder vor zwei wochen
das ist erstmal ein gutes anzeichen so
nenne ich erst mal aber wir müssen jetzt
einen schwimmer würden sie sagen
hoffnungsschimmer also das ist natürlich
eine schöne headline nachher aber darum
geht es ja nicht versuchen dass alle
zugreifen also nein ich finde ich finde
es auch wichtig das einzuordnen weniger
stark steigen reicht noch nicht
wir müssen herunter
und deswegen ist mir halt wichtig nicht
nicht zu sagen so nach dem motto wir
sind schon da wo wir hinwollen da sind
wir noch nicht wir sehen erste anzeichen
dafür dass eben die dynamik der sing das
ist weniger stark steigt dass die
richtung stimmt aber wir müssen
tatsächlich noch deutlich weiter
herunter und diese maßnahmen gelten
jetzt seit dem zweiten november noch
nicht mal eine woche und die wahrheit
ist halt die infektionszahlen die heute
morgen gemeldet wurden die geben er das
infektionsgeschehen von vor einer noch
nie mehr wieder
also werden die maßnahmen ob und wie
weit sie einen unterschied machen erst
mitte/ende dieser nächsten woche hatte
die nächsten tage wirklich wirklich
sehen können erstmalig möglicherweise
auch noch ein stück zeitversetzt und das
ist eben das was gerade so schwer fällt
uns allen mir ja auch man braucht geduld
ich gucke auch jedem hobby
natürlich halten optional in der form
für realistisch dass wir anfang dezember
wieder unter der 50 sind bundesweit das
ist möglich aber es ist am ende eben
auch ein parameter den ich stand heute
achter november noch nicht noch nicht
sagen kann
wissen sie was mich vielmehr beschäftigt
es werden eine debatte zwischen drin die
haben ja auch hier schon geführt und
anderen stellen
das wird natürlich nicht nur auf die
infektionszahlen schauen bestimme ich
übrigens absolut zu alleine reicht das
nicht es geht um die dynamik es geht
natürlich auch um die frage wie kann das
gesundheitswesen damit umgehen
aber es ist jetzt schon klar ich bin
eine ganz einfache rechnung jetzt
wirklich nur mit aber damit man die
größenordnung hat wenn von 20.000
neuinfizierten an einem tag etwa zwei
prozent in die intensiv medizin müssen
was eine größenordnung ist die die nicht
unrealistisch ist dann sind das 400 am
tag wenn etwa das intensivmedizinische
behandlung begleitung jetzt nehmen wir
mal an 15 tage dauert im schnitt so in
etwa auch die größenordnung 400 x 15
sind 6000 und eins kann man heute schon
sagen wir werden diese zahl von 6000
intensiv patienten die in deutschland
wegen cupid 19 behandelt werden müssen
die werden wir erreichen
die haben wir auch im november noch
erreichen das ist im grunde schon schon
absehbar am ende und das ist ja das was
was dann
doch auch wieder ein stück berechenbar
macht im wahrsten sinne des wortes am
ende geht es dann eben tatsächlich auch
mittlerweile ja um auch mathematik an
dieser stelle und an dingen die wir die
wir vorher sehen können in verschiedene
zeitversetzt passieren ich will nur
sagen 6000 intensivpatienten kurve 19
das schafft das gesundheitswesen noch
aber dann auch schon unter ziemliche
anspannung was personal angeht was
arbeitsbelastung einige zu malen kurven
19 patienten das ist ja richtig in
voller schutzausrüstung das ist eine
körperliche mit einem filter glas machen
und die all diejenigen die gesagt haben
aus nachvollziehbaren gründen schaut
nicht nur auf die infektionszahlen den
kann ich halten nur sagen wenn die
intensiven medizin mal zu voll ist
überfüllt ist überlastet ist dann ist es
zu spät ich meine da liegen das geht ja
am ende tatsächlich um patienten die
echt schwere monate haben uns zu viele
die da die dafür sterben und deswegen
müssen die zahlen runter trotzdem noch
mal auf diese november regelung sie
haben ja dadurch dass sie gesagt haben
jetzt erstmal nur vier wochen haben sie
ja einerseits erstmal für große
depression gesorgt ja mist wieder vier
wochen der blogger und gleichzeitig nur
hoffnung geweckt
es ist das hintertürchen da das ist im
dezember anders wird dass wir wieder die
harten regeln oder härteren regeln
zurückdrehen
das heißt jetzt plant man weihnachten
natürlich vor allem er will wissen und
ganz viele geschäftsleute interessiert
ist vor allen dingen
warum bekommen die nicht mehr
planungssicherheit warum können sie
nicht sagen
im moment sieht es danach aus lockdown
über november hinaus oder eben nicht
er weise weil weder sie noch ich dieses
virus an oder abschalten können
ich meine das ist ja am ende ist es ja
nicht nach dem motto wir wollen die
bürger im unsicheren lassen oder wir
wollen keine ich würde es unheimlich
gerne eine perspektive verbindlich
verlässlich geben können aber dieses
virus ist halt dynamisch und entwickelt
sich dynamisch das haben wir auch
gesehen wir haben im sommer eine zeit
wohl nicht wenige gedacht an bord haben
wir alles geschafft ist irgendwie weg
dieses virus so hat dem motto so ich
habe bundestags reden gehört die haben
mehr oder weniger suggeriert wir sind
durch und jetzt haben wir eben erlebt
und zwar nicht nur in deutschland
sondern ja in ganz europa und in vielen
ländern bis hierhin noch mal viel auch
schwerer und schwerwiegender als bei uns
wie schnell dieses virus zurück ist und
genauso wie es wichtig ist perspektive
und zuversicht zu geben und ich habe
weiterhin zuversicht wir haben es im
frühjahr mal zusammen geschafft und wir
werden es jetzt auch im herbst und
winter zusammen schaffen da bin ich fest
von überzeugt genauso wie es wichtig ist
perspektive und zuversicht zu geben
genauso ist es wichtig nicht irgendwie
falsche versprechungen zu machen und
stand heute achter november ich kann
halt noch niemand versprechen dass ende
november alles wieder stehen lassen
wollen die christina hilton heißt und
lebt im berchtesgadener land gehen ganz
genau in bad reichenhall und dort im
berchtesgadener land gab es ja noch mal
härteren locker und da wurden auch die
schulen wieder geschlossen weil
plötzlich die zahlen hoch geschossen
sind am 20 oktober wurde das dort
beschlossen ich schaue mal ob frau
hielten schon da ist da sehen wir sie
ich grüße sie danke dass sie noch einmal
für uns da sind am abend
ich weiß dass sie wirklich anstrengende
zwei wochen hinter sich haben auch schon
ganz anstrengende wochen und monate im
frühjahr hinter sich hatten wie setzt da
so ihr fazit nach diesem jahr wieder
harten locker und wochen im
berchtesgadener land alleinerziehende
mutter mit zwei kindern frau hielten es
war sehr hart aber ich freue mich etwas
morgen wird schule anfängen und das
hoffentlich ist endlich wieder alles
geregelt verläuft aber die letzten
wochen waren wieder trat uns einige
kinder ganz gehen sie keiner kann sagen
er sagt der gesundheitsminister
natürlich gerade weil das virus kann man
wieder an noch abschalten gehen sie im
moment davon aus dass sie jetzt da erst
mal durchs gröbste durch sende
berchtesgadener land oder sind sie im
grunde ständig ständig alarmiert das
jederzeit wieder die schulen schließen
und sie dauern doch wieder ihren alltag
um organisieren müssen
genau das ist ja die größte angst von
uns allen dass sich etwas ändert dass
wieder der lok daum wieder so kommt ihm
aus die letzten zwei wochen hatten und
das ist ja auch eine frage an die
ansprachen können sie mir versprechen
dass das nicht mehr so vorkommen dass
nicht mehr komplett alles geschlossen
wird und die kinder darunter leiden und
wir alle ja abschließend versprechen das
ist die wahrheit kann ich sie es nicht
ich kann ihnen nur sagen das wäre ja
eine klare priorität haben übrigens auch
eine die wir schon
seit monaten ja auch immer wieder
deutlich machen für ich glaube das ist
auch eine die eine hohe akzeptanz hat
nämlich kita und schule weitestgehend im
regelbetrieb unter pandemie bedingungen
weil das wichtig für die kinder und für
die eltern ist das waren ja sehr harte
monate die zeit der schließung und vor
allem auch wirtschaft und handel so weit
es geht im regelbetrieb um arbeitsplätze
zu sichern das ist sozusagen die
priorität und deswegen haben wir uns ja
eben dann auch entschieden in anderen
bereichen wo es um freizeit kultur kunst
geht wobei immer auch wichtig ist weil
ich heute in kohlers wir würden kunst
und kultur unter freizeit verbuchen das
tun wir nicht sondern das sind sozusagen
nebeneinanderstehende bereiche in denen
jetzt dieser lockdown leid wie es ja
heißt tatsächlich eben passiert weil
irgendwo müssen wir kontakte reduzieren
also unser ziel ist um ihnen das
sozusagen unser ziel ist es dass kita
und schule so lange es geht im
regelbetrieb bleiben können und
idealerweise durchgängig wenn sie mich
fragen kann ich ihnen das versprechen
abschließend dann ist die ehrliche
antwort das kann ich nicht weil ich auch
am ende wie sie auch halt mit dieser
situation jetzt auch in der dynamik
umgehen muss also ich find es noch
schlimmer ich würde ihnen jetzt was
versprechen und ich könnte es nachher
nicht halten dann wären sie wären sie zu
recht enttäuscht
das ist leider freunden im moment ganz
offenbar die unbefriedigende antwort wir
alle sind mit der belastung zu hause
gleichzeitig ersparen hat die nur
versprechungen zu machen die er wie er
sagt im moment möglicherweise seien gar
nicht einhalten kann vielleicht noch
einen weiteren punkt danke frau hielten
dank ihr im moment im alltag ganz große
rolle spielt die schulen haben wir
gerade angesprochen da werden jetzt
immer wieder massenweise klassen nach
hause geschickt für 14 tage in
quarantäne
dann sind die 14 tage vorbei das ist ja
jetzt ein ding was ich ständig
wiederholen wird wahrscheinlich über den
winter und dann im neuen jahr erst recht
wieder das heißt wir tauchen immer
wieder in die quarantäne rein und 14
tage damit damit rechnet sie im moment
das ist das was uns über die nächsten
fünf sechs monate begleiten wird also
zuerst einmal was kitas und schulen
angeht finde ich ganz wichtig
wissensstand heute acht elfter muss man
auch immer dazu sagen weil wir auch da
immer wieder neue erkenntnisse haben mit
dem was wir heute sehen und wissen
sind insbesondere kitas und grundschulen
jedenfalls keine infektion also bei der
grippe zum beispiel sind nicht selten
die kitas das kennen eltern auch er die
drehscheiben eines virus nach allem was
wir über dieses virus bis jetzt sehen
aus den studien in begleitenden der
kindergärten und schulen ist das nicht
der fall bei den kindergärten und
schulen das heißt aber nicht dass wir
natürlich die infektionszahlen in der
gesamtbevölkerung steigt dann sieht man
auch was in kitas und schulen aber es
ist sozusagen nicht die dies beschlossen
davon gehen sie aber nach wie vor aus
das ist richtig erkennen das ist die
erkenntnis lage die wir stand heute
haben und ich sag noch mal vor allem mit
blick auch auf grundschulen und kitas
also scheint auch eine altersfrage zu
sein ab einem bestimmten alter das ist
auch die erkenntnislage heute
robert-koch-institut sagte ab 13 15
jährigen fängt sozusagen ein bestandteil
auch das infektionsgeschehen es
insgesamt zu sein das ist wichtig finde
ich auch eine wichtige erkenntnis und
botschaft aber gleichzeitig gilt dem
auch umso mehr infektionen es insgesamt
im land gibt desto häufiger ist dann
halt auch mal eine erzieherin einer zehe
ein elternteil ein lehrer eine lehrerin
oder auch eben ein schüler infiziert und
sozusagen spiegelt sich dass da wieder
was ich möchte ist mit den
gesundheitsämtern mit dem robert koch
institut mit experten jetzt auch noch
mal auf die quarantäne auf die
kontaktpersonen nach verfolgungs regeln
schauen ich habe es ja nur selbst erlebt
sozusagen auch im eigenen bereich der
kontaktperson das im moment auch einfach
falls diese hohe überlastung gibt und
diese sehr starker anforderung an die
gesundheitsämter wir noch mal schauen
müssen wie wir und einheitliches
vorgehen habe was die quarantäne länge
angeht was die frage angeht dann testet
man wen auch in der quarantäne und was
bedeutet ein negativer test ist das eine
abkürzung der quarantäne oder nicht also
was ich sehe ist dass das im moment ganz
ganz unterschiedlich gehandhabt etwas
was
wünschen sie sich also moment kann man
nicht verkürzen wenn man ich möchte
erstmal hin zu einer größeren
einheitlichkeit wieder die wir jetzt
sozusagen in dieser besonderen
belastungssituation verloren haben an
manchen stellen wie wir sie auflösen da
geben sie uns einfach noch zeit ich will
den das ergebnis ja nicht vorweg nimmt
ich möchte mit den praktikern aus den
gesundheitsämtern haben wir jetzt auch
schon ein paar runden auf natürlich
jetzt nicht ganz entscheidende zeit
nicht zum zum herbst winter in klammern
die wagen auch wenn ich selber wichtig
jetzt auch nicht einfach irgendwas zu
sagen weil das ebenso ein wichtiges weil
das sehr beweglichen ich habe ja gesagt
das sind stand jetzt einige
hunderttausend deutsche in quarantäne
und natürlich ist die frage wie mit
quarantäne umgehen und wie wir mit
texten umgehen einer die ganz viele
menschen betrifft und deswegen finde ich
ist das jetzt nicht zu spekulieren
sondern das werden wir jetzt tatsächlich
sie kennen die debatten ja gibt es
unterschiedliche einschätzungen zu der
frage
das werden wir jetzt noch mal auch auf
arbeiten noch einen punkt aus
berchtesgaden wo wir gerade waren wir
wollen da einmal kurz auf die statistik
gucken wie sich dort die zahlen die
institute verändert haben seitdem
zwanzigster oktober also zwanzigster
oktober wie gesagt war da das harte
lockdown lockdown datum wo auch die
schulen geschlossen haben da war danach
ging der wert noch mal hoch bis heran an
die 300 und mittlerweile sind wir ein
bisschen runter aber nicht wirklich weit
davon entfernt also bei 50 wie sie
wissen beginnt ja der rote bereich
sozusagen und in berchtesgaden immer
noch deutlich über 200 das heißt lesen
sie daraus ab selbst so einloggt und
bringt eigentlich nichts oder bringt
erst ganz spät war es nämlich erst nach
wochen wochen wochen später das ist ja
was was wir tatsächlich auch in
deutschland aber auch in ländern wie
spanien italien anderen ländern im
frühjahr gesehen haben dass das bremsen
und vor allem das runterbringen von
zahlen die einmal hoch sind tatsächlich
eine ganze zeit dauert und wir hatten ja
im frühjahr als miteinander haben hatten
es geschafft mit einander dass die zahl
also waren sehr frühzeitig sozusagen
dann darin die welle zu brechen so
frühzeitig das ja eine gesagt haben ist
gar nichts passiert er gar keine
maßnahmen machen müssen ist ja dieses
präventions- paradox dass wir nichts
passiert dann einige sagen sie ist aber
gar nicht nötig was natürlich
quatsch ist weil es ist nichts passiert
weil wir es gemacht haben also ist es
damals gelungen die bälle sehr früh zu
brechen und wir sind aber in ländern und
haben gesehen in ländern die hohe
infektionszahlen erreicht hatten im
frühjahr dass das sehr lange gedauert
hat sich auch die die zahlen aus
berchtesgaden würde ich überhaupt keine
hoffnung haben dass ist nach november
besser läuft werden selbst der starke
lockdown in berchtesgaden in vier wochen
eigentlich kaum wirkung zeigt dann
machen wir bundesweit locker und der
nicht ganz so hart ist und der soll
jetzt in diesen vier wochen die zahlen
deutlich runter bringen also nicht nur
stabilisieren wie sie gesagt habe
sondern runterbringen ist extrem
unwahrscheinlich
na ja das ist ja natürlich noch mal was
anderes so zu sagen ob sie es regional
bezogen haben und das ja trotzdem
natürlich gab ja die möglichkeit zum
arbeiten woanders hinzugehen am ende ist
immer die frage sozusagen wie werden
infektionen wieder reingetragen auch
dann in familiären kontext und ein
anderes hinein das ist das ganze land
ein stück in der entschleunigung
runtergefahren in der kontakt
beschränkung
aber ich habe vorhin schon mal gesagt
ich sehe noch nicht dass wir diesen
winter wieder größere veranstaltungen
haben wir mit größer meine ich nicht 500
sondern die erkenntnis der letzten
wochen ist doch es ist vernünftig jetzt
mal über viele wochen wenn nicht monate
über den winter keine veranstaltungen
mit mehr als 10 15 20 leute zu haben
wenn überhaupt weil das sind genau die
ereignisse
viele in einem raum ein oder zwei haben
es dass das ein jahr berlin die
teilnehmer gefragt worden was ist nicht
so schwierig an diesem virus und das
schwierigste an diesem virus ist ja das
ist infektiös ist ohne dass man schon
selber merkt dass man deswegen der
vergleich noch einmal zurück da dann
soweit es ja wirklich hoch interessant
dass wir haben diesen kleinen feld
versuchte ein berchtesgaden da machen
die alles dicht da machen die sogar die
schulen dicht und die kitas dicht
und da wirkt es in diesen vier wochen
kaum die mühe machen nicht die schulen
dicht und wir hoffen dass in vier wochen
die wirkung drastisch ist drastisch das
jedenfalls die zahlen deutlich
runtergehen ja gleichzeitig sehen wir
aber eben die bremsspur es lang also das
wird jetzt nicht gleich nach zwei wochen
also von 2 bis 16
in allen facetten überhaupt sichtbar
sein dass wir spürbar unter sind
entscheidend ist dass wir bis dahin
überhaupt mal sehen dass sich
stabilisiert und die richtung dann
stimmt aber bis wir wieder richtig
runter sind ja das dauert eine zeit das
ist ja die erfahrungen die wir haben und
am ende komme ich aber immer wieder
darin das rücklicht sehr an uns allen
auch wieder dieses virus hat eine
inkubationszeit von ein paar tagen das
heißt ja jede neuinfektion muss
irgendwie vor ein paar tagen
stattgefunden haben und wenn es eben so
lange dauert bis zahlen runter geht
heißt es ja erst finden immer noch ohne
dass man es weiß meistens ja dann im
familiären kontext oder längeren text
infektionen statt und da hilft am ende
eben dass wir aufeinander acht geben
diese diese praktischen fragen
beschäftigen die allermeisten wie geht
es nach november weiter auch wenn sie es
immer wieder gleich natürlich
beantworten müssen noch mal ein beispiel
aus offenbar von harry kakas der dort
ein fitnesszentrum dem ein
fitnesszentrum gehört der fitnesspark
offenbach und er fragt oder fordert
machen sie auf ersparen zum ersten 12
220 den kein opa so begründet er das
wünscht sich doch nach dem tod dass sein
enkel pleite geht und zum sozialamt muss
das stimmt wahrscheinlich aber noch
besser wäre ja wenn opa weiterleben kann
jetzt um in diesen saloppen beispiel zu
bleiben und es dem enkel wirtschaftlich
gut gehen kann das ist doch unser ziel
und aber auch in dieser saloppe
formulierung macht natürlich auch aber
da habt ihr also nennen will ist das
ganze der gedanke wichtig am ende wegen
wir das habe ich vorhin schon gesagt
sehr guter gegner ab und wir werden ja
auch die frage gegen ante up wie steht
es um gesundheitsschutz wie steht es um
die frage dass wir das gesundheitssystem
nicht überlasten überfordern wollen
es wurden daraufhin in der intensiv
medizin gegen die wirtschaftlichen
folgen die das auch sehr hart hat wie
eben gerade auch beim freizeitpark in
der gastronomie schausteller künstler
viele solo selbstständige am ende ist
das ja auch ein ablenken von
unterschiedlichen gütern interessen
freiheit
und das ist ja keine entscheidung die
sich irgendjemand leicht macht völlig
klar kampers fragt kann nicht aufmachen
erfordert machen sie auch zum zum ersten
zwölften kann er damit rechnen ja oder
nein ihre antwort weiß noch nicht leider
ja weil ich finde noch wissen sie wir
leben am meisten in dieser krise erweise
von ja auch vertrauen uns dem zutrauen
der bürgerinnen und bürger darin dass
der besten wissen und gewissen gehandelt
wird und ich finde das vertrauen am
meisten gefährdet am meisten verloren
gehen lässt ist eben dinge zu
versprechen die dann nicht eintreten und
deswegen gerade deswegen weil diese
pandemie und sind in der lage bringt wo
wir mehr denn je aufeinander vertrauen
müssen unter belastung unter stress
vertrauen müssen finde ich es ganz
wichtig nicht unnötig vertrauen zu
verspielen und versprechen machen die
man nicht wirklich zu 100 prozent halten
kann
geht das risiko ein vertrauen noch eine
ganz praktische frage zu diesem ganzen
komplex sie kommt von stefan kolb aus
duisburg und er sagte er werde am 6
februar im nächsten jahr 50 jahre alt da
die einladung schon raus geschickten
saal gemietet wie weiter sparen würden
sie sagen dass ich feiern kann oder
nicht wahrscheinlich wieder selbe
antwort aber jetzt der ratschlag bis
wann kann ich warten oder solche gesten
lieber schon absagen
naja das ist eine schwierige
entscheidung
sozusagen in dieser konkreten in dieser
konkreten beratung aber ich bleib schon
dabei und ich würde jetzt mal februar
noch unter winter fassen
an dieser stelle kalter jahreszeit dass
wir zumindest mal für die nächsten
monate die wintermonate auf feiern wie
gesellig sein verzichten sollten im
großen langsam im großen wie im kleinen
und insofern ja erst mal so wenn man für
sich selbst die dinge frühzeitig klar
haben will sagt man im zweifel
frühzeitig ab und freut sich dann darauf
so oft mache ich mit meinem vierzigsten
auch den ich im mai eben nur sehr klein
gefeiert habe
ich weiß auch nicht ob ich jetzt im mai
nächsten jahres ich gehe mal davon aus
stand heute anders feiern kann einfach
nur verzweifelt den 42 also ich finde
halt auch ist das noch mal
das ist ein jahrhundert pandemie dass so
etwas und vor allem in so einer
vernetzten
deren komplexen gesellschaft ich meine
spanische grippe 1918 das war eine ganz
andere gesellschaften und mal auch in
der arbeitsteilung übrigens auch im
familienleben in vielen anderen facetten
war das noch immer eine ganz andere
gesellschaft in so einer vernetzten
modernen industriegesellschaft hat es
das noch nie gegeben und deswegen ist
das eine zeit die uns gerade alle
ziemlich fordert herausfordert und
erfinde ich so hart dass jetzt auch
wieder für die gastronomie ist oder den
wert und den veranstalter
da finde ich das verschieben einer feier
noch ein vergleichsweisen milden
eingriff in meine freiheit also klingt
so dass der februar eben auch noch
extrem unsicher ist und herr kolb der
bundesgesundheitsminister sagt er
in der ich sage vielleicht kann
stattfinden aber sicherheitshalber
vielleicht er absagen im moment ist
nicht die zeit für feiern war ein
anderes was ich in den vergangenen tagen
gefallen sind das bleibt auch so passen
und nehmen dass das was jetzt unabhängig
davon ob nach november wir wieder ein
stück lockern könnte da nicht sicher der
fall bleiben wird über den winter ist
das in geschlossenen räumen
veranstaltungen
ich habe es vorhin schon mal gesagt in
der größeren zahl und mit ein bisschen
aber natürlich draußen feiern also da
kann man dieses buch schon sagen damit
meine ich an der stelle glaube ich kann
also da kann man ja schon mit hoher
sicherheit sagen
sagen wir es mal so rum dass das im
winter nicht statt
ein schritt weiter frage kommt von elke
stopper aus dem kreis tübingen kommt sie
und sie fragt sich warum soll sich
jemand eigentlich an die regeln halten
wenn man sieht wie auf diesen demos im
moment jeder macht was er will ist ja
echt nicht lustig sagt sie vor allem
weil ja auch keiner dann eingreift
obwohl die regeln nicht beachtet werden
werden das in leipzig gesehen hat sparen
am wochenende wieder 20.000 wanderer auf
den straßen noch ein paar bilder aus
leipzig die menschen dort wirklich ja
alle ohne maske so wie man es auf den
demos eigentlich erwartet auch da sehen
was vom vom wochenende
das heißt die konkrete frage warum soll
ich mich an die regeln halten sagt sie
wenn die doch sowieso machen
tja das ist eine gute und
nachvollziehbare frage von vorstopper
demonstrieren demonstrationsfreiheit ist
ein sehr wichtiges grundrecht freie
meinungsäußerung und die möglichkeit
also ihm zusammen zu tun und da sollten
wir unbedingt so weit es geht möglich
machen aber man kann halt auch
demonstrieren mit abstand und mit maske
also das widerspricht sich ja nicht und
es gibt im klare auflagen wie für andere
weil das muss jemand dass er sagt sie ja
auch das muss dann halt jemand
kontrollieren also keiner will die
demonstration verbieten ja auch
hinterher in berlin und den muss und die
er dann auch am ende am ende aufgelöst
hätte man es doch kontrollieren müssen
was heißt kontrollieren sie ist ja
aufgelöst worden weil sie die auflagen
nicht eingehalten hat nach stunden ja
wissen sie das ist doch auch für die
behörden überhaupt keine leichte
situation auch da übrigens
verhältnismäßig vorzugehen wollen sie
jetzt ein wasserwerfer auffahren weil
leute den also ist ja total schwer als
stellen sich mal vor sie sind der
verantwortliche der das entscheidet das
auch in der abgewogenen
verhältnismäßigkeit zu machen was mich
vielmehr beschäftigt weil wir die bilder
gerade gesehen hab ich frage mich immer
was ist das
warum ja die maske nervt zum beispiel
nur weil die maske ist also das symbol
für alles die die maske nervt ich hätte
sie auch lieber öfter mal nicht tragen
müssen oder sogleich auch lieber ins
restaurant ohne als noch restaurants
offen hatten
klar gehe ich lieber in den bundestag
oder man ist überhaupt kein thema aber
die frage ist doch ist das wirklich so
eine große belastung dass man mit der
aggressivität wie sie ja gerade ich habe
mir gar nicht gehört was da gerufen
wurde aber manchmal sind das volk und
mein land ist ja dass man mit so einer
aggressivität und mit diesen mit diesem
vorwurf dieser unerbittlichkeit dann da
wirklich darauf reagieren muss das
entscheidende ist doch dass ungarn chef
sanjay was dann passiert etwas das ich
versucht deswegen auch immer wieder aufs
neue soweit es irgendwie geht auch immer
wieder das gespräch zu suchen und
einander zu verstehen was ist das das
aus so einer frage wie maske tragen wie
gesagt nervig aber eigentlich doch ganz
harmlos auf einmal so eine aggressive
wir kommen und so total blöd vor wir
regeln jetzt unser weihnachtsfest laden
noch tante und onkel aus weil das eben
dann die zwei haushaltsregeln nicht mehr
einzuhalten ist und warum sollte
beispielsweise morgen dann jemand in
leipzig in der fußgängerzone seine maske
tragen wenn noch die demo am wochenende
war ja und die demo ist aber ebenso
nicht genehmigt worden und hätte so
nicht stattfinden sollen
wann wie was wo hätte dann aufgelöst
werden sollen es wird derzeit
aufgearbeitet ich find ich wüsste die
diejenigen die immer aus dem studio
heraus dann schon mal alles besser
wissen was in leipzig hatte was ich habe
gehe ich nicht also in leipzig hätte
passieren müssen ich das wird jetzt in
leipzig da bin ich sehr sicher sind
einfach alle vorbilder einfach trittin
ich sagen da bin ich ja voll bei ihnen
aber ich halte nichts davon
diejenigen die da jetzt als
sicherheitskräfte sicherheitsbehörden
die verantwortlichen in der polizei in
der stadtverwaltung das sind ja auch
sehr schwere entscheidungen
abwägungsentscheidungen weil jeder weiß
wie verheerend die bilder sind und
gleichzeitig sehe auch verhältnismäßig
altstadt mit der staatsgewalt gegenüber
dem demonstrationsrecht umgehen müssen
das sind ja lauter dinge die sie abwägen
müssen und ich tue mich manchmal schwer
damit wenn sozusagen dann immer schon
nach drei stunden alle bei twitter oder
sonstwo kommentierend wissen was in
leipzig oder sonst was ich halt einfach
ein hund über die leute reden ich mich
auch auf aber ich darüber rede ich ein
gelungen also beim vermummungsverbot
gibt es ja auch entsprechendes vorgehen
was wollen sie dann fragen mal anders
und was würde denn teilweise machen wenn
er da ich bin zum glück nicht in der
lage das heißt ich dass ich mich raus
rede zum glück nicht in der lage das das
entscheiden zu müssen ist es eine totale
schwierige entscheidung eine möglichkeit
wäre diese demo wo man wusste wer die
veranstalter sind gar nicht erst zu
genehmigen am ende ja aber zum beispiel
ist sie war ja genehmigt für einen
anderen ort ganz anderen ort wo es im
zweifel solche bilder noch nicht gegeben
hätte in leipzig und dann hat ein
verwaltungsgericht weg ist richtig
erinnere doch gesagt ist die richtige
entscheidung in die nächste instanz hat
ein paar stunden vorher gesagt
gerichtsentscheidung und das ist halt so
im rechtsstaat
die darf dort stattfinden dann müssen
sie damit umgehen wenn sie ein paar
stunden vorher als verantwortlicher
erfahren ob die demo findet jetzt noch
woanders statt unter anderem kontext mit
wahrscheinlich auch größeren
schwierigkeiten dinge zu kontrollieren
und das will ich ja nur würde ich ja nur
sagen ich finde es unbedingt wichtig
auflagen bei einer solchen demonstration
ich finde es demonstrieren wichtig aber
ich finde eben auch die auflagen abstand
hygiene alltags max gewichtig und
gleichwohl bleibt es weiterhin eine echt
schwere abwägungsentscheidung für die
der verantwortung haben und deswegen
würde ich einfach vorschlagen lassen wir
das jetzt dein leipzig mal aufarbeiten
was da passiert ist und dann wird das
auch besprochen werden müssen so oder so
ja in diesem winter wie gehen wir
eigentlich generell mit diesem
demonstration noch mal ganz konkret zu
dem der morgen in der leipziger
fußgängerzone sagt wisst ihr was ihr
könnt mich mal ja die laufen damit
20.000 durch die stadt ich ziehe mir
hier nicht mehr die maske auf wasser als
idee und dem sage ich erst dass ich sein
erster impuls versteht den verstehe ich
gut das aber zweitens damit halt auch
kein kein keine gesellschaft keine
familie keine gemeinschaft zu machen ist
also nach dem motto da halten sich ein
paar kleine regeln also halte ich mich
auch nicht mehr in der regel ist halt
ein bußgeld nur der wird im zweifel noch
kontrolliert da verweise ich weiß es
doch aber trotzdem funktioniert auch
start und zusammenleben nicht wenn man
das sozusagen nach dem motto macht weil
sich da nicht an regeln gehalten wird
halten wir uns jetzt auch nicht mehr an
regeln so funktioniert auch in der
familie schon ich versuche immer wieder
auch mehr deutlich zu machen wie würden
wir das denn eigentlich in der familie
handhaben und auch in der familie gibt
es noch nicht mal ein 2 diese ich so an
gar nichts halten wollen aber dass ich
aufgehört habe davon noch jetzt nicht
die logik erwachsen aber dann macht
jeder seins und deswegen ist es ja auch
wichtig klar in den botschaften zu sein
deswegen ist es auch wichtig regeln
durchzusetzen übrigens nicht nur auf der
demonstration das gilt ja auch für die
frage auflagen die wir an anderen
stellen haben die es in der gastronomie
gibt gab und wieder geben wird wenn sie
wieder öffnet und in anderen bereichen
da gibt es wahnsinnig viele die halten
sich sehr penibel an alle regeln weil
für sie auch viel davon abhängt in der
wirtschaftlichen existenz und die
schwarzen schafe die es überall gibt die
es nicht tun
ich finde dann ist es eben auch wichtig
dass da eine konsequenz zu spüren
nächste frage kommt von einem zuschauer
der ihn möglicherweise etwas bekannt
vorkommt lieber herr minister sparen
hier ist der kino ich grüße sie aus
tirol
ich möchte ihnen jetzt gerne eine frage
stellen
was werden sie für die korona
risikogruppen menschen über 60
zu der ich und auch meine frau hannelore
gehören in zukunft tun
alle maßnahmen die wir ergreifen den ja
vor allem darum auch diejenigen die am
härtesten getroffen werden können von
einer infektion zu schützen
das will ich übrigens noch mal genug
kurz einfach normal seien zum thema
risikogruppe wir sehen dass das risiko
für einen schweren oder schwersten
verlauf auch tödlichen verlauf wirklich
sehr stark vor allem alters trainiert
das heißt also tatsächlich um so älter
und zwar richtig stark steigen ab 60 und
nochmals viel stärker steigen ab 70
desto höher das risiko es gibt auch noch
andere risikofaktoren aber alter ist ein
sehr klarer faktor der sich auch in
vielen vielen studien herausschält jetzt
muss man mal sehen ich wenn ich manche
debatte in deutschland so sehe und lese
und verfolge über risikogruppen dann hat
man ja so das gefühl da gibt es ein paar
die gehören dazu die muss man irgendwie
ein bisschen drauf aufpassen und der
rest kann dein leben als wäre nichts das
muss man mal sagen deutschland ist nach
japan das zweitälteste land sind eine
einzige risikogruppe ja ein bisschen ist
schon so wir sind das zweitälteste land
der welt bei uns sind 23 millionen
deutsche über 60
wenn sie die wir sind ein wohlstandsland
zivilisationskrankheiten diabetes
bluthochdruck übergewichtigkeit auch
alles risikofaktoren für dieses virus
wie für andere erkrankungen im übrigen
auch wenn sie nach den definitionen
gehen sind 30 bis 40 prozent der
bevölkerung risikogruppe und genau
deswegen ist die wirksamste maßnahme zum
schutz bin ich wieder bei dem thema aha
regeln lüften aufeinander aufpassen was
wir zusätzlich machen für die ganz
besonders gefährdeten die höchst
betagten zum beispiel eine
pflegeeinrichtung oder ambulant zu hause
ist ja das thema stellt es jetzt sofort
dort prioritär einzusetzen seitdem es
die gibt schutzmasken natürlich
prioritär einzusetzen besuchs konzepte
auch beim impfen wird man sicherlich vor
allem auch die risikogruppen mit zuerst
impfen
also unterschiedlich wort aber eines
finde ich wichtig für diese
risikogruppen debatte in deutschland
immer mehr zu sehen dass im grunde jeder
in seiner familie mit sicherheit einige
hat die zu der definition dieser risiken
haben dass die antwort an heino
stichwort impfstoff womit rechnen sie
den moment wann kommt er nach ihrer
prognose derzeit noch dieses jahr oder
im nächsten jahr also wir rechnen und
planen damit anfang nächsten jahres
das ist ein erster impfstoff und erster
impfstoffdosen geben kann aber es ist
sehr wichtig zu sehen dass das erstens
das ist jetzt sozusagen stand 8 er
elfter wissen schon heute was wir sehen
ist impfstoffentwicklung kann immer auch
rückschläge haben und gerade bei
impfstoff entwicklung ist es aus meiner
sicht sehr wichtig jetzt auch einfach
diese phase 3 studien die er laufen für
die ersten im wasser ist phase 3 das so
seien die letzte studie studienphase wo
teilweise 40 tausend probanden also
freiwillige neben getestet wird im
vergleich impfstoff oder placebo wie die
entwicklung ist also ein sehr großer
zahl größer als sonst
und das ist deswegen wichtig weil so ein
impfstoff wird ja anders als medikament
gesunden kämpft und zweitens hunderten
millionen wendig wahrscheinlich
milliarden menschen in den nächsten
monaten jahren wenn es einen gibt
verimpft werden und deswegen müssen die
studien gut sein und niemand kann
ausschließen selbst kurz vor der
zielgeraden so zu sagen dass es in einer
solchen studie noch etwas gibt wo man
dann sagt nehen
den können wir nicht zuschauen deswegen
stand heute optimismus sozusagen für
anfang nächsten jahres
aber auch da muss man einfach ehrlich
dazu sagen es kann auch noch ein
rückschlag wie lange würde das dauert
kann auch noch einen schlag so gegeben
wie lange würde es dauern bis dann
deutschland sozusagen durchgeimpft wäre
ja es wird schon ist wirklich ganz
durchgeimpft ist von denen die wollen
wir machen ja freiwillige impfung wird
sicherlich monate dauern
weil das ja auch eine enorme logistik
erfordert ist nicht übrigens eltern die
bundeswehr helfen oder wie würden sie
das überhaupt organisieren also wie
würden sie das verteilen es liegt auch
daran welcher impfstoff
wir haben impfstoffe die mit einer
bekannten technologie arbeiten weg ich
will es nicht zu viel aber weg dort also
das sind impfstoffe die viele von uns
auch schon bekommen haben in der
technologie die kann man das ist der
entscheidende faktor bei zwei bis acht
grad also
frank temperatur transportieren im
stoffel aktiv wie supertoll gekühlt
werden musste und diese impfstoffe die
können wir auch in der normalen
logistikkette fahren die könnten mal
sogar wenn wir genug davon haben
irgendwann auch in normalen arztpraxen
verhindern wie alle anderen auch dann
gibt es m rna das ist eine neue
technologie die braucht tatsächlich - 60
- 70 grad jedenfalls stand heute für
transport und lagerung und das kann man
natürlich nicht in jeder arztpraxis
machen oder auch so einfach
transportieren und dort gibt's spezial
logistiker und oder unterstützend auch
auf bereiche der bundeswehr deren
geimpfte oder können sich auch
vorstellen dann wenn die logistik
geklärt ist dass in krankenhäusern zu
machen den altenheim mehr geld wichtig
also wir das eine sind ja die die
impfzentren die sozusagen die impflinge
ist auch ein wort das sie noch mal neu
gelernt haben die impflinge dann die zu
impfenden dann dann auf suchen und
aussuchen können müssen aber natürlich
kann jemand 85 jährig pflegebedürftig im
pflegeheim nicht zum im zentrum
das ist da dass ich hätte sicherlich
sozusagen um die impfzentren drum herum
wenn man so will
mobile teams auch geben können die
länder planen dass auch das ist ja im
föderalen miteinander ein zusammenspiel
von bund und den 16 bundesländern das
nur zu klappen
naja es ist es gibt anders rum auch
stärker weil eben 16 mal auch mit
entsprechender politischer verantwortung
ja gearbeitet wird aber jedenfalls wird
die mobile teams eben dann auch geben
die in krankenhäuser oder oder in
pflegeeinrichtungen daneben auch im
morgen morgen tag das corona kabinett
wird dann auch beschlossen wer zuerst
dann kommt mit dem impfstoff und wer
zuletzt nein was ich habe ja die
ständige impfkommission die leopoldina
und die im deutschen ethikrat gebeten
zusammen zum ersten mal zusammen in
einer arbeitsgruppe
zumal die rechtliche ethische
medizinischen grundlagen für eine solche
priorisierung ist wir arbeiten das wird
morgen vorgestellt
werden auch von den drei institutionen
und dann können wir auf basis sozusagen
dieser grundlage erst dann wenn wir über
den impfstoff mehr wissen dann die
konkrete priorisierte entweder ist eben
kurz erklären
wir müssen ja jetzt die studien abwarten
für wen die impfstoffe der impfstoff der
jeweilige besonders gut verträglich ist
oder vielleicht auch besonders schlecht
verträglich ist ob aber ab einem
bestimmten alter ist probleme gibt oder
anderes mehr
und deswegen können wir die konkrete
priorisierung erst machen wenn wir über
den impfstoff mehr wissen
aber ich finde es trotzdem wichtig das
ist eine politische aber auch eine
gesellschaftliche im zweifel an jedem
mittagstischen der debatte darüber gibt
in der familie auf arbeit sag mal wie
findest du das eigentlich wer sollte
eigentlich zuerst geimpft werden zuerst
der der das größte risiko hat beruflich
weil er im krankenhaus arbeitet oder in
der pflege
zuerst der oder diejenige die ein
besonderes risiko hat weil risikogruppe
eltern journalisten und mode zuletzt
oder hier die sowieso aber das ist ja
nur ein faktor noch nennen womit der
debatte oder delhi ganz besonders viel
kontakt zu anderen haben die these gibt
es nämlich auch wir müssen eigentlich
zuerst die impfen die jeden tag am
meisten s bahn fahren leute waren und da
wären sie wieder ganz vorne dabei aber
so ein bisschen ist eine populistische
frage vielleicht aber die frage kommt ja
schon und bundeskabinett jetzt oben oder
nein das ist genauso dran
es gibt sicherlich kolleginnen und
kollegen im bundeskabinett in der
risikogruppe
die werden dann via restrisiken europa
dran und andere müssten im zweifel
länger waren das mass der hand haben wir
genauso wie für alleine muss dass ein
gesetz genau regeln ihrer meinung nach
diese priorisierung oder kommt man ohne
aus wir haben ja heute auch schon
priorisierung bei kämpfen beim
grippeimpfstoff beim herpes zoster bei
pneumokokken es gibt ja überall
empfehlung wohl es übernommen wird von
den kassen und boden nicht das ist ja
auch eine form von priorisierung
entscheidung
das macht mir heute auf basis eines
gesetzes die ständige impfkommission
ich glaube bei diesem impfstoff in
dieser pandemischen lage macht es schon
auch sinn dass das noch mal politisch
und auch gesetzlich rückgekoppelt wird
müssen im parlament reden was das
richtige verfahren es hat eine
verordnung des ministeriums
andere wege aber ich finde schon wichtig
dass diese debatte noch einmal
stattfindet einfach nur es so zu machen
wie immer fand ich jetzt angesichts der
pandemie lage nicht als der bundestag
soll es absegnen am ende auch das
verfahren auf jeden fall ja eine frage
die auch was ganz anderes nochmal zielt
die kommt von manfred meyer aus dresden
stellte die frage und er sagt in
dänemark sind deswegen jetzt zahllose
nerze getötet worden ja weil das virus
mutiert ist schreibt er davor haben wir
bei der bekämpfung der pandemie die
möglichkeit der übertragung wie nerze
vögel hunde katzen und ratten sträflich
unterschätzt und wie wahrscheinlich ist
es eben das ähnlich wie in dänemark so
notiert des virus auch in deutschland
auftaucht also das
friedrich-loeffler-institut das ist ein
bundesinstitut dass ihm mit der renn er
mit die ziehen sich von einem
beschäftigt hat geschaut auch vor allem
was auch nutztiere aus tiere in
deutschland angeht die tiere die wir in
deutschland gemeinhin halten bergen das
risiko nach erkenntnis stand heute nicht
nerze werden in deutschland nicht so
gehalten wie in dänemark auch zu
kommerziellen nutzung finde ich übrigens
die zahl ich glaube über 10 millionen
ärzte dort wurden jetzt gecallt
natürlich zum schutz aber ist ja auch
erst mal war es wohl darüber wo man
schon noch mal eine sekunde nachdenken
welche größenordnung und den dimensionen
das hat wir sind sehr schnell mit den
europäischen kollegen den dänischen
behörden in kontakt gewesen als man die
grenzen gleich dichtmachen müssen oder
stellt das land frei
wir haben natürlich haben wir über alle
optionen auch nachgedacht aber nach
allem was wir bis jetzt an erkenntnissen
haben ist vieles eher spekulation als
tatsächlich wissenschaftlich fundiert
auch im engen austausch mit den mit den
dänischen kollegen aber die ideen gehen
eben und das ist ja auch richtig auf
nummer sicher sie wollen also überhaupt
gar kein risiko eingehen das was ist das
problem nur um einen einsatz zu sagen
dieses mutierte virus ein mutiertes
virus ein sich veränderndes corona virus
dann könnte es sein dass der impfstoff
nicht mehr funktioniert weil der
impfstoff setzt hier auf klaas bekannte
virus und sozusagen sein wenn es in
einer gewissen breite sozusagen jetzt
noch 200 dann geht es noch aber wenn es
zu sehr sich verändern würde
dann könnte sein dass der impfstoff
nicht mehr wirkt und deswegen haben die
dänen eben sehr vorsorglich jetzt diese
maßnahme noch eine frage ganz praktisch
auch die kann von unseren zuschauern wie
ist das mit der maske wenn man
brillenträger ist wir alle kennen das
oder brillenträger wissen schlägt so
leicht wie machen sie das dass die
brille nicht beschlägt bei masten tragen
oder haben sie schlicht für die selbe
problem und ich hatte natürlich fest
gleiche problem wie alle anderen
brillenträger auch meine erfahrung ist
aber also erstmals wichtig die
praktischen dinge des alltags einfach
auf der nase an dingen zu haben und von
dem auftritt weil die fotografen ihr
dann auch jeder jeden brillen beschlag
sozusagen bei mir gerne mit
fotografieren
ich habe immer den eine funktioniert
auch ganz gut wenn man sozusagen an
annan trägt wie nennt man das dann schon
mal 20 minuten vorher auf falls du schon
mal was sie geben soll dann eine
schlechtes anschließend auch nicht mehr
so stark oder problemen haben haben wir
alle als brillenträger
vielen dank herr gesundheitsminister
einen schnellen sprung noch mal in die
usa zu dem thema das uns natürlich auch
ganz ganz wesentlich die letzten tage
bewegt hat der us-präsidentschaftswahl
dieser kaugummi wahl die sich über so
viele klare gezogen hat seit gestern
eben gibt es ein ergebnis sind sie froh
dass sie kampflos werden
ich kann mit dieser art der debatte
ehrlicherweise nichts nichts anfangen
das ist eine wahlentscheidung der us
bürgerin und us bürger gewesen vor vier
jahren ist es jetzt eine
wahlentscheidung
und ich finde es unsere aufgabe auch als
vertreter der bundesrepublik deutschland
mit der gewählten regierung dem
gewählten präsidenten der vereinigten
staaten von amerika einem unserer
engsten unserem wichtigsten verbündeten
außerhalb europas dann auch in
zusammenarbeit mit sie erleichtern das
ist ja am ende auch ich ich ich sehe
natürlich möglichkeiten und optionen
anknüpfen zu können auch an fiel vielen
von dem was joe biden sagt und und an
politischen vorstellungen hat aber ich
finde es halt auch einfach wichtig so
ist mein verständnis für eine
bundesregierung und als bundesminister
in dieser regierung
das sozusagen so einfach zu machen diese
schwarz weiß dass das dann manchmal dann
in den sozialen medien woanders
stattfindet wir müssen am ende bleibt ja
gar nicht mehr zum beispiel der seit
gestern weltweit sind alle erleichtert
sagt er hier ja das ist ja auch okay ich
finde halt nur trotzdem wichtig im
zusammenspiel in der zusammenarbeit
zwischen gewählten regierungen einfach
auf warte ich meine das ist doch was
passiert in dem land warum hat auch
donald trump jetzt noch mal 70 millionen
stimmen
ich finde man muss aufpassen dass man es
eben nicht verkürzt sondern dass man
dass wir sehr klar wahrnehmen was da in
den usa passiert wie gespalten dieses
land auch ist es gibt ein schönes zitat
von alexis visa noch talk talk talk will
dass das ich vorhin sah deswegen hab ich
mir das noch mal aufgeschrieben der
citizens die weitere camps hat er über
die wahlen über wahlen 1835 geschrieben
viel grip sie enter a country also dass
das sozusagen rund um wahlen ist in den
usa auch mal hoch her geht wenn man mal
das beschreibt er aber und der
entscheidende unterschied da wollte ich
dahin ist ja das ist hier nicht mal um
eine wahl herum hoch her geht sondern
dass das was ist was wir jetzt seit
jahren sehen diese immer stärker
werdende spaltung in den usa politisch
selbst die masken frage in der pandemie
ist ja eine geworden wenn die maske
trägt ist der motorradgespanne anderes
jeder frage ein gespaltenes land und das
beschäftigt mich dann gehen wir dass wir
das 0 2 wie verhindern wir dass das bei
uns passiert weil wir sehen ja erste
ansätze durchaus auch in anderen
westlichen gehen wir einmal ganz kurz in
dieses wie sie sagen so tief gespaltene
land und zwar nach pennsylvania nach
gevelsberg gehen wir gettysburg in
historischer ort dort wo eine große
schlacht im amerikanischen bürgerkrieg
stattgefunden hat und dort gehen wir zu
williams tore und er ist einer von
diesen ungefähr 70 millionen jump
wählern in diesen tagen
und er war auch auf der straße in diesen
tagen als es darum gegenstopp bekannt
auch da ist er mit auf die straße
gegangen hat sich auch dafür ein gesetz
ist uns zugeschaltet wie gesagt aus
gettysburg schönen guten abend und schön
guten nachmittag bei ihnen herr sowie
die wahl wurde angeblich gestohlen sagt
der us-präsident donald trump stimmt
dass nach ihrem eindruck sie haben in
pennsylvania gewählt stimmt da nach
ihrem eindruck dass es da ja aber
einigen dingen nicht so mit rechten
dingen zuging
das stimmt ich habe ihn ja für den kampf
gestimmt ich kann nicht so urteilt
sicherheit sagen tja die wahl ist
gestohlen worden
aber zu sagen es gab möglichkeiten und
das ist möglich
ich als amerikanischer bürger und dann
von anderen lästigen wollen eine
gründliche überprüfung nach prüfung
haben dieser warnschilder jetzt habe ich
schon gesagt sie sind einer von diesen
70 millionen menschen das heißt die jump
gewählt haben das heißt selbst wenn der
us präsident dann irgendwann doch aus
dem weißen haus verschwinden würde
natürlich bleiben die 70 millionen trump
wählern was wird aus denen was wird aus
ihnen was wird aus ihnen in der
politischen debatte in den usa
ich meine schon dass er viel davon
abhängen welche maßnahmen in den letzten
paar wochen ergriffen werden sie haben
völlig recht 70 mio
die menschen haben dafür gestimmt die
werden nicht verschwinden und über nacht
ihre meinung ändern ist nein ich hoffe
doch dass wir eine anstrengung sehen
klarheit zu schaffen transparenz
herbeizuführen und wirklich einfach
nicht zu drehen denn für die daten die
ich habe unter anderem das ist
lebenswichtig für die gesundheit der
amerikanischen republik dass wir nicht
nur das nur ihren diese streitpunkte die
das sind szenen während dann ihres
wahlrechts beraubt und ich muss das
nicht extra sagen aber in einer
demokratie wenn man das ignoriert dass
man betrogen wurde ist das kein rezept
für eine gesunde gesellschaft oder für
gesunde wahlen die die zukunft sehen
hinter ihm eine ganze menge an waffen
das bringt mich nochmal zu der frage wie
das in den nächsten wochen eigentlich
weiter geht also rechnen sie damit dass
der gewalt auf die straße noch mal
vermehrt getragen wird eben von
enttäuschten jump wählern wütenden tram
fehler
ich glaube ich das nicht ich erwarte
keine gewalt wie ich das schon gesagt
habe als ich mit den kollegen in
philadelphia gesprochen habe ich bin ich
hingegangen regen an der konfrontation
ich meine mal doch dass die leute auf
dieser seite am nicht so konfrontationen
rausgegangen sind leider ist es tatsache
die amerikanische gesellschaft
politische gewalt in vielen fällen hat
auch in anderen ländern der welt ich
erwarte keinen starken anstieg dieser
gewalt oder eine andere unerwartete
entwicklung nein danke herzlich ist aber
für die interessanten stellung mit einer
aus pennsylvania aus gettysburg jens
sparen bei uns unser gesundheitsminister
teil der bundesregierung was könnte man
jetzt machen mit 70 millionen
enttäuschten teilweise wütenden und auch
ehrlich gesagt am system auch an den
wahlen durchaus zweifelnden wählern was
ich sehr wichtig finde was man noch mal
sieht wenn jetzt mal so lange stück
zurücktritt ist doch wie wichtig für
eine demokratie für eine repräsentative
demokratie die legitimität und
legitimation von wahlen ist das also
wahlen am ende auch so stattfinden
können dass sie eine hohe akzeptanz
haben und das vor allem aber auch allen
klar ist dass das gilt dann auch wenn
erstmals rechtlich noch einmal das sind
normale prozeduren aber wenn dann das
ergebnis feststeht
demokratie ist nicht nur darum macht zu
gewinnen durch mehrheiten sondern
demokratie lebt vor allem davon dass
macht wieder abgegeben wird und dass ein
übergang gibt und was man eben sieht und
was ich immer wieder aufs neue auch ein
stück verwundert finde ist dass ein land
wie die vereinigten staaten von amerika
ein wahlsystem hat das so zersplittert
ist in jedem bundesstaat ein ein anderes
und wo ist irgendwie stellen vor werten
16 ich manchmal auf deutschland da muss
ich nicht haben wir 16 verschiedene
bundesländer 16 verschiedene systeme wie
die bundestagswahl stattfindet die post
weil die stimmung in unterschiedliche
abläufe briefe die noch keiner weiß
genau wie viele tage später ankommen 16
unterschiedliche regeln wie ausgezählt
also dass das ist etwas das erklärbar
ist aus der historie aber am ende
offenkundig sozusagen durch verfahren
entsteht legitimität und legitimation
das kennen wir im großen wie im kleinen
das ist bei der vereinsvorstand zwar so
dass ist in der partei so und das ist
dann sozusagen ganz besonders so bei
einer solchen präsidentschaftswahl oder
einer bundestagswahl und das finde ich
ist das entscheidende auch noch mal wo
man verzweifelt ihr halt schon dran das
ist so ein tick tick zu spät quasi schon
wie würden sie denn jetzt aber ich hoffe
ich kann einfach nur ich ich ich wünsche
mir einfach dass wir auch in unseren
westlichen gesellschaften immer wieder
aufs neue uns bewusst machen wahlrecht
und wahl details das klingt manchmal
langweilig ist aber wahnsinnig wichtig
für akzeptanz am ende und das zweite ist
jetzt und das fand ich am ende wird ist
ja auch deutlich geworden in dem
gespräch das am ende das ergebnis dann
aber auch eben akzeptiert wird und
werden kann und dann auch von donald
trump akzeptiert werden wird und werden
kann das werden wir ja in den nächsten
tagen sehen aber damit ist das land ja
noch nicht wieder versöhnt miteinander
und und dieses sozusagen sondern wenn
zum kampf von gut und böse wird wo es um
feindschaft geht und nicht um politische
gegnerschaft wo am ende ein ergebnis
nicht akzeptiert wird weil es das nicht
das ist was man sich selbst erwünscht
denn wenn das anfängt und vor allem wenn
das immer weiter zunimmt dann halten sie
am ende und das ist das was wir in
teilen der usa sehen dann halten sie
eine gesellschaft nicht mehr zusammen
und dann geht es doch immer weiter
auseinander und das ist ja die große
aufgabe jetzt dann für den neuen
präsidenten für joe biden und seine vize
präsidentin harris das überhaupt wieder
zusammenzuführen dass wir da zu schaffen
das ist ja das ist eine aufgabe die man
sich immer wieder vergegenwärtigen muss
und die am ende dann ja auch gar nicht
so viel spielraum gibt also du musst ja
am ende aufpassen dass du da nicht noch
mehr wieder verlierst und noch mehr
enttäuscht und gleichzeitig hat er dann
auch in diesem fall 74 75 millionen
wähler so viele wie noch nie in der
geschichte der usa die gewählt haben und
für uns in deutschland in den westlichen
demokratien und die frage beschäftigt
mich übrigens in dieser karuna pandemie
die wir hatten das bei leipzig vor allem
kurz auch wie vermeiden wir dass es bei
uns zu ähnlichen spaltungen kommt wir
sehen ja auch ansätze durchaus in
deutschland in den deutschen debatten wo
sozusagen jeder in seiner echo kammer
ist jeder in seiner whatsapp
ist jeder bei facebook nur noch das
liest was er selbst schon immer dachte
und die fähigkeit miteinander
unterschiede auszuhalten
meinungsverschiedenheiten auszuhalten zu
wissen dass man dinge nicht gleich sieht
aber trotzdem zusammen gehört in einer
nation dass wir uns das auf jeden fall
erhalten und erhalten müssen den 20ern
genauso wie die vereinigten staaten
rechnen sie damit letzte frage dass
unter joe biden die korona zahlen in den
usa herunter gehen deutlich runtergehen
durch die wahl eine sicherlich noch
nicht sondern jetzt kommt es darauf an
er hat ja auch angekündigt jetzt auch
noch mal mit experten schauen zu wollen
auf die maßnahmen und da auch natürlich
eine erste priorität zu machen
aber es hängt natürlich am ende auch von
den von den maßnahmen und den
möglichkeiten hat übrigens auch die usa
da kann ja nicht auch nicht einer
zentral durch regieren sondern da gibt
es ja auch noch die die bundesstaaten
herr 00 de trump als zentral vorgeworfen
trotz der bundesstaaten wurde gesagt der
hat die hunderttausende sind in den usa
zu fassen schwierig was schwierig wird
und was wir bis hierhin weitestgehend
die maske ist ein bisschen auf dem weg
dahin als symbol
aber wir haben sie eben bis hierhin
weitestgehend vermeiden können dieses
virus zu politisieren ich habe vorhin
schon gesagt in den usa wo die frage wie
siehst du es mit dem virus am ende
wahlkampfteam von von republikanern
gegen demokraten wert rechnen maske wird
recht keine und das ist nicht gut ein
virus und der kampf gegen ein virus das
alle trifft und betrifft also zu sagen
so zu politisieren und wenn das gelänge
das wieder aufzulösen dann wäre das
schon
der umgang mit roma wird schon
bundestagswahl thema werden
wahrscheinlich nicht man jetzt in den
usa ja auch da sozusagen fachlich
sachlich auch an vielen stellen darüber
zu reden was ich mir für die globale
pandemie bekämpfung wünsche ist sehr
stark dass die usa unser partner bleiben
auch in der weltgesundheitsorganisation
die den verdi die usa wieder eintreten
wir sind ja noch drin
dass ein jahr übergangsphase aber die
die usa sind ich hatte die am freitag
noch eine schalte mit den g7 kollegen
die usa sind natürlich eine unserer
wichtigsten wenn nicht der wichtigste
partner auch in einer organisation wie
der vero finanzielle ressourcen
politisch in den allen aspekten und die
frage ob wir weltgesundheit globale
gesundheit in der pandemie und in den
20er jahren gestalten können oder nicht
die hängt natürlich auch davon ab ob ein
land wie den ohren wie die usa mitmachen
sonst würden sie damit china übrig und
die usa ihn nicht mehr drin das heißt
dass eine botschaft heute an den
gewählten präsidenten joe biden kommt
zurück oder geht gar nicht erst raus aus
der weltgesundheitsorganisation vielen
dank bundesgesundheitsministerin sparen
heute zur corona sprechstunde ich glaube
es hat geklappt sehr viele fragen der
zuschauer leser zu beantworten heute
herzlichen dank dafür nächsten sonntag
sind wir zurück 21.45 die richtigen
fragen live bei bild
[Musik]